hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
your Lord and Savior Jesus Christ well
Jesus and I are gonna watch today 10
best movies where the hero learns
nothing just like Jesus yeah I knew it
all along
I knew all the things we're gonna
character art really decided one of our
top reward tiers over our patreon
whatever video you request you must
definitely do put up on the air tubes
today comes from Cameron French and this
is a video from what culture a channel I
love it love their list videos and I
love their commentaries let's check it
out let's get some spoilers in our lives
sometimes movies can teach us life
lessons Tyler told me not to like
Groundhog Day taught us that Bill Murray
is utterly brilliant and liking has
taught us if you're gonna kill the king
don't leave any witnesses however there
are many many films which because they
center around having a good time and
that little laugh of your pals mean very
little and protagonists actually don't
learn anything at all they don't have a
moment which inspires change and end the
movie in very much the same way that
they began but with a few more hijinks
and wackiness in their rearview mirrors
like everybody's hero learns nothing
habit and Ferris Bueller's Day Off
Ferris Bueller's Day Off is one of those
great movies that people enjoy on a
superficial level as a youngster and
once they come of age realize just how
much of an [ __ ] Matthew Broderick's
titular protagonist actually is but it's
still a great movie though invention
although we'd likely see first change
for the better maybe becoming a little
less sociopathic along the way
however in this he's pretty much the
same throughout cocky defines and
there's little sign that he wants to
change going forward it's actually so
apparent that it's led many to believe
that Cameron is actually the main star
of the film as he actually goes through
the more traditional arc of changing and
challenging Authority however as far as
Ferris goes well he's just a monument to
being a dick number 9 scarface scarface
is one of pop culture's well he brags
disses
by the crime genre for three decades
protagonist Tony Montana really doesn't
encounter any personal growth or change
throughout Brian De Palma's iconic
thriller I mean you could say that
welder that's because he dies at the end
but there are lots of films that use
death as the moment of realization and
this isn't it
Montana is as much a ferocious scumbag
when he's fresh off the boat from Cuba
as he is when he's huffing a giant pile
of cocaine and annihilating goons with a
grenade launcher during the film's
unforgettable climax the Empire blooms
but the man stays largely unchanged as
he's never content more leads to more
and it will never be enough it's strange
therefore that Breaking Bad is often
cited as a successor to Scarface when in
reality they couldn't be further apart
in their presentation of their
antagonists number eight No Country for
Old Men the Coen brothers have quite a
bit of a habit of presenting us with
characters who don't change much
throughout their journey he's the dude
in in 2007 their unconventional approach
one of them three Oscars including Best
Picture now in fairness No Country for
Old Men doesn't really have a fixed
protagonist with George Tommy Lee Jones
and Javier Bardem pretty much standing
on equal footing as focal characters and
each of them is very much the same
person at the end as they were when that
first presented to the audience though
the viewer expects most to have a
climactic showdown he's killed before he
can go through any sort of
transformative heroic experience while
Belle is left powerless to battle the
violent world around him and have yeah
well he just escaped look the money you
could argue that Belle's final
realization that he's just waiting for
death
it's an epiphany of sorts but it's not
exactly that the guy was a paragon of
utility and youthfulness throughout the
film he's still on the same axis just
going through the motions number seven
Skyfall though the Daniel Craig James
Bond movies person it's fair to say he's
still a corridor of a human just going
from angry - well angsty - founds a more
tortured and haunted pond but follow up
Skyfall saw the spy hunker down into a
more typical routine yes the film begins
with him bad
be wounded and drinking himself into a
stupor on a beach but bond learns
precious little from both his
interactions with fellow former agent
round silver and the Avenger and death
of M at the end there's no implication
that he's learned to better appreciate
human life or even acknowledge his own
expendable nature and everything he's
experienced just reinforces his decision
to be cold and detached almost exactly
like he was at the beginning of the film
the wolf of Wall Street Scorsese's
oscar-nominated epic drama was largely
praised by critics it did receive some
criticism for Scorsese's failure to
outwardly demonize the actions of
corrupt stockbroker Jordan Belfort I
took a seminar school saves its other
words all revolve around making the
audience fall in love with the ideas of
excess than making them feel sick by the
end because of how truly excessive it
all is it's a very clever way of making
the audience revile characters without
actually out-and-out saying that they're
bad people sell me this multi-purpose
lesson with this the more classic
version of this story would see him
learn the error of his ways
this version is true to real life and it
shows him without much regret and
forging ahead with the same title an
exploration that's shown beginning at
the film now so I always feel sad
watching this film seeing as your mum's
scene got cut you know the one with the
Rhino and the funnel and the sperm yeah
I mean she did it anyway regardless of
not having it being film but it just
wasn't the same it was just very very
sad
American Psycho now here's an
interesting one as well Patrick Bateman
goes through a lot of things in the film
namely murder sexual depravity and
returning videotapes come the close of
the story he's exactly the same he's
sweaty and a bit shaken but he's still
embroiled in a world of greed dinner
reservations and business cards and it
becomes very clear that he's gotten away
with whatever crimes he's committed he
will never change because there's been
no catalyst to make I guess I've got
inside this list this is Ricky Nasus
yeah continues to elude me and I gain no
deeper knowledge
myself no new knowledge can be extracted
from my telling this confession has
meant nothing so yeah
Bateman carries on and so do we
unsatisfied with the results but unable
to do anything about it
number four Nightcrawler when
Nightcrawler opens lead Lou is a sleaze
bag with little regard for other people
and when the film ends he's exactly the
same person just lose so is there's no
relief for the audience either and the
only character who represents some
semblance of a conscious ultimately ends
are corrupted and shot dead for his
troubles it's a very grim venom mystery
of the film that may be on attitude
towards disposable media and our decent
citation through over exposure to
violence is something we need to address
but that's for Lou well he's more than
happy to keep providing footage as long
as he fits in to the model provided
number three young adults drama deep
revolves around Mavis Grey 37 year old
woman Sheldon who knows the films in the
most alcoholic narcissistic sociopath in
a clear state of Arrested emotional
development and that's exactly how she
remains for the entire movie despite
being told multiple times to grow up and
get over herself she doesn't even take
baby steps towards any type of change
literally vowing at the end of the movie
that she's fine the way she is and vows
to never change I did see this room one
minor moment of self-reflection where
she considers the possibility of
becoming a more mature person the court
d shrugs it off and restores the status
quo in the process to be fair though
self-improvement is hard so why bother
dollars because ultimately another Bond
movies more for Eastwood's grizzled
insanely cool performance the man with
no name
aka blondie is more of a vehicle than a
character having virtually no backstory
nor much of an indication of his
personality or feelings about anything
beyond killing and making money and
that's totally fine for the needs of the
movie even when blondie has to
occasionally make moral decisions in
everybody feels like it comes from a
place of change or growth his sole
motivation is to better himself
financially and there's never any
suggestion that he might be starting to
develop a soul one a serious man with
Jewish physics professor Larry don't
only wanna heaven first leave him he's
denied tenure at his job and he's
effectively blackmailed into giving one
of his students a passing grade
Larry spends much of this movie
wrestling with his faith to God and
asking various religious figures about
the meaning of it all though none of
these men provide anything beyond
ambiguous unsatisfactory answers and so
the film ends without ever giving Larry
the solution or personal PC desperately
searched for he agrees to give the
students a parson almost immediately
afterwards learnt of a grim medical
diagnosis while the gigantic tornado
looms over his son's school it's all
very heavy and as the film is inspired
by the book of Job Larry is left
clueless and without any immediate
meaning to the events it inspires the
same questions within the audience as to
the meaning of religion and whether you
should have faith but for poor Larry
well he learns nothing and is soon to be
reduced to nothing as well fun stuff
right and there we go those were 10 of
the best movies where the protagonist
learns absolutely nothing learned
absolutely nothing its to not stop
plugging the t-shirts that I got the
sale over a shop what culture comical
one per list once and we've got having a
giraffe once please come and support me
while she's the challenge more this big
bold PowerPoint right here you can't
receive me but I am just drink to myself
go follow me at retro J with zero over
on Twitter and as always I've been Jules
you've been awesome I'll speak to you
soon bye now you guys can subscribe the
reject nation cuz we've learned nothing
when the same as when we started this
video yeah I guess like the first half
of this video I was like but what they
do mean change they evolved with that
I'm like okay well I was getting the
title mixed up with the the concept of
character art because yeah allies
carries the ark you definitely get to
Splore them like I think there's movies
like wolf of wallstreet American Psycho
and Nightcrawler
where it's about watching them sort of
not evolved but devolve hashtag deep yes
something monstrous
and watching the way that affects the
people around them yes porting
characters kind of changed for having
interacted with them and you still learn
more about them as the film progresses
it's not to say that they're just this
stagnant character
I feel like bond if a there is that one
or like the man no name tends to be that
one to where you barely learn anything
different about them like Skyfall it's
kind of a unique case because it sets
itself up to have an arc in a lesson
where he's like I'm not with mi6 anymore
he's washed up on the beach he drinks
all the time he's not doing this myself
and he starts getting back into the game
can't really shoot he's out of shape so
it kind of just ends later on Aubrey
Bardem becomes or interesting than him
yeah it's a great movie but when you
look at it like it does set itself up
for some kind of character art but you
don't really get that with him it seems
like a problematic proposal for Bond in
general to have yeah Scarface is that's
the whole point is he doesn't learn
though like that's yeah that's a big
part of his lesson is that he doesn't
learn his lesson and that then the
consequence of that is he dies
cautionary tale where that's why
Breaking Bad is a successor in some
fashion Vince Gilligan did say that
Breaking Bad has his inspirations drawn
from Scarface watching this guy evolved
into that like Walter wise who never
learned who had a million opportunities
to go back like he Rx he learned some
[ __ ] sure by the end of it all he never
left what he was doing and then he has
to pay the consequences for that and
it's very similar to what Scarface has
to go through here and no country for
old men it's also unique case because
it's has such a weird structure yeah I
was thinking when that one started was I
was like well who is the actual
protagonist of this movie because we do
have these central figures that we keep
cutting back to and we don't really know
much about any of it yeah and even when
some people die I remember like they
talk about it here
so I'm gonna talk about it like what
josh brolin dies you don't see his death
they just walk into a hotel room and
he's dead it's so weirdly told they
don't really get room for that but
that's another one where it's like human
study you're watching the situation and
how these characters behave in there so
yeah you're not watching the critical
moment at which they're about to change
like most movies would you're just
watching the various situations play out
with them in them yeah yeah it's like
some people might take it as to have a
character they need to have an arc or
they need to learn something by the end
or whatever but sometimes there's more
to having character than just that it
can just be exploration like the Joker
is not the main character in The Dark
Knight is the antagonist but he's a very
constant character who doesn't learn
anything but no one's gonna say he's not
a character yeah characters arguably
ought to learn something but if you're
good enough as a writer they don't have
to well I mean if you look at a majority
this list them Mortimer anti-heroes yeah
yeah Scarface got Jordan Belfort you got
Miles Fisher Patrick Bateman yeah I
don't remember young adults but she
sleeps with Patton Oswalt it has like a
broken penis or something
oh she fixes his dish he learns to after
you know being all self-absorbed and to
be a little child she sleeps with a guy
who would never successfully get
Charlie's then I'm gonna say I beg you
oh if American Psycho was the one that
kind of pushed me because I was sitting
here thinking well towards the end
doesn't he kind of have like a breakdown
that you could kind of classify as at
least flirting with the change but then
I was realizing like he flirts with a
change or you know simply revelation he
has the breakdown on he's on the phone
yeah cause lawyers act as if he's made a
mistake yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
freaking out and then you know we see
that that doesn't carry through
necessarily and we're sort of left to
wonder but I felt like that left
something there
I think Mary Poppins could be on this
list she's the main character if she
learned that movie
there's nothing just keep on keepin on
yeah doing her Mary Poppins thing she
does
diddly squat I mean the way everyone
reacts to her why change puppets Mary
Poppins says oh well Mary Poppins knows
yeah I mean I still think it's a good
list I don't disagree you would their
lists you know what it's easy to confuse
what the topic is something else you
know yeah but I do think it's an
interesting topic because that's one of
the things we talk about the most is
like character arcs in the growth yeah
like that and it's fascinating to see
movies that can succeed without those
things yeah all right well thank you
what culture for this awesome list and
Thank You Cameron French for requesting
this Cameron French you know he actually
was really opening up to me about how
bummed out he was about the lack of
nominations for reddit arey received at
the golden limb you know you know Toni
Collette she really learned she learns
about her family history but she really
learned something that changes her not
really make sense but yes this is pepper
this video hope you're doing well buddy
I know we've been talking a lot lately
this guy and I like to go back and forth
plenty about you know forth uh-huh back
and forth what you know like never mind
over you there you know what a sex joke
cuz copulation activities usually are
back in forth motion you know I usually
talk back and forth about what movie do
you love that other people hate him or
what movie do you hate other people love
and we like to really discover our
difference of opinions and not just
agree on things he's such a fun guy to
talk whether he's been one of our top
pledges for such a long time so Cameron
I just want to give a really sincere
thank you to the amount of time you've
been with us at our patreon page and
whether you haven't changed your pledge
that this entire time has been like
crazy to us and so you've you've been
one hell of a supportive guy and you're
a big contribution of what's kept the
channel alive so thank you buddy I
really love the hell out of you and
hopefully in person one day we will get
to meet anyway guys thanks for watching
it long what's your favorite movie where
a character doesn't learn diddly squat
comment below you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell and check us on
patreon TV show reaction watch along as
weekly q and A's this guy does music
video coverage check it out